hello everyone and welcome to this
webinar
my name is muyrodan and i work as a
project leader at violex
an organon a tip company that has been
working in the last years
in establishing an organomatic model of
the alveolus
today i will be talking about how
systems like this like the language
are boosting the introduction of the
three-year concept into research
drug development and toxicology from the
land perspective
but first which systems do we have
available to study the lungs
for sure the first-hand information from
the patients at the clinics is the most
reliable and close to applications for
humans
followed by the research that can we can
do in their tissue samples
and also in explicit systems but if we
think about it as it comes from the
patients
this information is rather limited and
besides healthy tissues or individuals
are often missing
to compare if we want to get knowledge
about the biology in health and disease
we need a model allowing to turn on and
off the pathways to understand how they
function
or also introduce different disease
triggers so this of course is something
we cannot do in humans and that's why
animal models have been used for so long
during the years
even though using animals have provided
a lot of valuable information
more and more evidence is pointed that
these models do not replicate human
physiology as well as we thought they
did
and besides for obvious reasons they
raised multiple ethical concerns
so if they're not predictive which
alternatives do we have yeah sure we
have in vitro systems
that allow for high throughput
introducing modifications they are
normally simple to use
and we can also control the environment
however they are
too simple to extrapolate results to
what happens in the human body
so could we make the systems more
complex and introduce physiological
parameters to make them more predictive
the answer is yes and this is how
microphysiological systems were born
these inhibitor models introduce
different features of the imbue
situation
including mechanical forces 3d
environment or different cell types
they are what we call advanced image
models and among them
we can find besides organs and chip also
micro tissues and even organoids
this technology is proving its potential
in many areas
including drug testing and they
represent a very good alternative to
reduce and replace animal models
mps can be applied at both basic and
translational research
including the development or healthy and
disease models that we can then use
for toxicology safety and efficacy
testing and also for personalized
medicine
putting this into perspective here we
have the example of the drug development
process
well as you probably know developing a
new drug starts by screening thousands
of compounds that are subsequently
introduced to a few
through in vitro animal testing and
finally clinical trials
bringing a new drug into the market is a
very long and expensive process
and mps can help making it shorter and
also more effective
more cost effective
ampules can be applied to the clinical
testing and normally during the little
molecule optimization
or during the definition of the
candidate drug compounds since they are
more protective compared to conventional
in vitro systems
more importantly they are very good
assets for safety and efficacy testing
and there is where the predictive
potential can help accelerate the
process
and avoid in some cases unnecessary
animal testing
now that we have this overview so mps
seem like a very good option
but they are quite complex and this can
sometimes be very challenging
so from the engineering perspective
which support architecture and forces we
want to integrate is key to develop the
right environment for the cells
in the case of the lung for instance we
need to introduce a soft and porous
membrane support
to allow for cell culture and ideally
this support should separate an apical
and vasculatural compartment
that we can assign to an air and a blood
compartment
then we need to introduce the forces
simulating the breeding motion
or also the blood flow and lastly if we
think of the structure
an open design would allow for an easy
access to the cells
and to develop the chip for exposure
applications
when it comes to the biology first we
need to think of which cell types we
want to use so we need to use
stem cells we want to go for primary
cells one
cell type or many this will then define
which cell culture medium is better
suited if we have a co
culture and this will intermodulate how
celtic cell communication is established
then in addition we need to define the
right microenvironment
in terms of the ecm or starcellular
matrix
so we can make the cells to fill and
behave
as they would be at home
so you can imagine with this many
components the options are almost
limitless
in the very recent history of the
language chip different models have been
developed for different parts of the
lung
including different cell types and chip
designs so we have to be careful when we
say lying on chip
because we have to consider that we may
be modeling different regions of the
land that can be
either upper airways small airways or
also the elbows
the alveolus is the smallest functioning
unit of the lung and that's why
i will be focusing on air blood barrier
models some of which i have shown here
in blue
all these models have something in
common and is that they
require a particular structure and cell
type to simulate the very thin
epithelial endothelial barrier that is
in charge for the gas exchange
so here i show you the language chip
system we have developed
so this system is comprised by three
modules including the docking station
that holds the chip itself and connects
it to the other two modules
then we also have the exchanger that
provides the support for the medium
exchange
and finally the breather which allows to
control the cyclic stretch
simulating the breathing function
so we focus now on the cell culture
plate as you can see here it has
exactly the same dimensions as a 96 well
plate
so the ax soft comprises two chips as
you can see here one to the right and
one to the left
and each of these chips includes six
individual cell culture units
accounting for a total of 12. each of
these units is composed by three walls
as you can see in the green box
from these three wells the central
chamber of the chip
holds a very thin porous membrane that
serves as support for the cells
and the cells can grow on either side of
it this membrane is very thin it's only
three micrometers thick
and it's flexible through the pores the
cells can also communicate
and as you can see here by sitting
alveolar epithelial cells on top
and endothelial cells at the bottom we
can recreate an in vitro
system for the upload barrier that is
very very thin and
holds no more than 15 micrometer
thickness
and finally we have the breathing
function this motion is inspired in the
movement of the diaphragm
and in this case what it did was
introducing a micro diaphragm within
each cell culture chamber
so this is a very thin membrane placed
at the bottom of the cell chamber
as shown here in grey that can be
deflected by the action of the breather
so then when the chip is filled with
medium this deflection can be
transmitted to the membrane that holds
the cells
shown in blue providing a breathing-like
stretch
the motion is in 3d and then the
settings are adjusted
so it can simulate the physiological
breathing pace in humans
in the video to the right we can see the
building function in action
as you can observe the 3d deflection is
clearly visible
with the cells in the outer part of the
membrane meaning slightly less deflected
than it was on the sensor
simulating then the in vivo situation
so with this model in our lab we have
developed different applications and
also biomodels
so one of them is focused on inhalation
through breathing we are continuously
exposing our lungs to particles of the
environment
these particles can cause adverse
reactions that happens with pollutants
or for instance with pollen
so we try to simulate a model that does
exactly this
for this we are developing a model
together with vitrocell that allows
combining
the lung on a chip technology with an
aerosolizing chamber
opening up the opportunities to expose
alveolar cells to different
molecules of our choice and also observe
their effects
for similar models here we have chosen
to use human alveolar epithelium cells
which are the first cells
that are encountered but any molecular
enters within the alveolus from the
other side
as you see this has come from a very
tight wire that we can observe here in
the graph to the right
represented by a very high
transportability resistance or tear
further applications of this model is to
use it to study the effect of drugs that
are
inhaled and they basically come through
the inhalation route
or studying new alternative subtract
delivery then in addition this in vitro
system could also serve to reduce or
replace
some instances some of the animal
experiments are being used in inhalation
toxicology
so here there are some examples of
applications we have used the system for
first we use syncoxal nanoparticles
which are a very common constituent of
many different products such as
cosmetics rubber concrete paints or even
sunscreen
we use different concentrations of
nanoparticles and we apply them in
dynamic and static conditions
on other epithelial cells we could
observe that the breeding conditions
made the cells more sensitive to zinc
oxide in this toxicity
particularly at the higher doses tested
which actually simulates an acute effect
out of those which
would be in range of the maximum amount
of zinc oxide nanoparticles accumulated
for an exposed worker throughout their
whole life
as a proof of concept we have also used
a molecule whose effects are very well
characterized
and in this case it was the well-known
proof of logic inducer of tgf beta
so we use this molecular repetitive
dosing using the cloud system
here we can observe that exposure to
this pro-fibrotic cytokine induce the
weakening in the barrier function
as we can observe here by the decrease
in tear and this was also associated to
a decrease in cell viability
the treatment with tgl beta was also
reflected in an increase in the
mesenchymal markers
collagen 1 and alpha smooth muscle
acting and a decrease in the gene
expression on epithelial ones such as
the cut hearing
and this suggests that ttsbit and
equalization is inducing epithelial
tumors and kind of transition in this
model
in the following example i show you a
model we are developing for cheap
applications
in this case we had a co-culture of
albero epithelial and endothelial cells
once the body was formed we used a
pro-inflammatory molecule in different
doses
and we could observe that there was a
dose-dependent effect on barium function
weakening
with the highest dose here four times
the dose
leading to almost a complete destruction
of the barrier
this was also correlated with an
increased permeability of the system
to small and big molecules
besides we could also assert that
endothelial cells
were much more susceptible to this
molecule than the epithelial ones
as we could observe both under the
microscope and also by a much more
pronounced cytotoxicity and the
endothelial layer
indeed the language shape can also be
used to study toxicology by following
inflammation
some lung inflammatory diseases such as
ardeas can lead to pulmonary edema
and immune filtration and this is a
signature of an impervary infection
and damage of both the epithelial and
the endothelial side
so to model these conditions we work
normally in aquaculture models such as
the one i showed in the slide before
in which we use human alveolar
epithelial cells and land micro vascular
cells
to simulate the capillaries then we
treat this co-culture system
with different molecules to simulate a
disease and then we can investigate new
targets and also test the efficacy of
normal
candidates we really believe that using
systems like this we can get very
valuable information directly from human
cells
that can prevent or at least refine the
conditions for certain animal studies
okay so keeping in mind the important
role of immune cells
in during inflammation we try to model
on the membrane if we could recreate the
recruitment process
so for this we seated endothelial cells
that you can see here in red
and we activated them with lps so it was
very nice to see that pb and cs that you
can see in green
were being actively recruited by the
activated endothelium
and after a certain period of time we
could observe that many more pnc's were
attached to the endothelial layer
in the presence of lps
but more importantly these cells were
not only recruited
they could also transmit right upon
attachment going through the endothelial
layer and then through the chip membrane
towards the other compartment
here there is another example of how
important it is to introduce
immune cells depending on the model in
this case
also triggered by lps we wanted to
observe how
we could develop a system trying to
stimulate the features for acute lung
injury or ards
induced by infection so here we use lps
as a trigger
and we could observe that only in the
presence of pbs
we had actually a decrease in the
barrier function here you can see that
is
quite a dramatic decreasing here this
was also accompanied by
an increase in this in the secretion of
pro-inflammatory compounds and in this
case it will style it
if you look what happens at the
endothelial side we can observe that
only in the presence of pb and
distributed with lps
there was a change in morphology with
endothelial cells
in their typical cobblestone shape
towards a more spindle-like
shape of the cells and this highlights
how important it is again
the role of immune cells in modulating
inflammation and toxicity and why we
need to include
the immune component in many models when
we want to recreate an individual
situation
another model we have been working on is
on trying to simulate the features of
idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis
so this disease is truly devastating and
it causes
scarring of the lung tissue and ends up
in fatal respiratory failure
so ipf is characterized by a thickening
and stiffening of the interstitial
spaces
in which normally an already sensitive
epithelium is functional epithelium
starts undergoing an abnormal tissue
remodeling and then finally their virus
structure is completely destroyed
so this disease has no cure up to date
and this is why predictive preclinical
models for drug efficacy testing are
essential
so we can accelerate the drug
development process and bring a solution
for these patients
for this we have developed a model
consisting on
human alveolar cells that we co-culture
with lung fibroids
and this can be treated with different
pro-fibrotic triggers such as for
instance tgf beta that is the one we are
using currently
so this could be applied for target
determination
as well as for efficacy testing as i
mentioned before
and at the same time it can serve as an
alternative tool for different animal
models are still do not resemble
completely
the human ipf features as it happens
with the blah myself model
here's some results of our experiments
so our data suggests that in our
epithelial fibroblast culture tgf-beta
does not have a significant effect in
decreasing barrier integrity
however in green conditions it seems
that there is a trend of
the treatment that it seems to decrease
already the barrier function from 24
hour onwards
if we look at the toxicity induced by
the treatment we could detect that there
was an increase in the epithelial cells
at 48 hours from tgf beta introduction
however the fibrous site was not
affected by this treatment
interestingly the effect on the
epithelium we could reverse by mint
adani
which is a drug that is currently on the
market for fibrosis
the cytotoxicity levels were reduced to
those of the entropy conditions
and these results support that the model
could be a good preclinical tool
to test the efficacy of new
anti-fibrotic drugs
finally the language chip also permits
to go one step closer to the clinics
as it is allowing to evaluate aspects
that are reserved
only to humans such as patient patient
variability
or also application applications such as
those
involving the human leukocyte antigen
so in the first place to study this
journal to donor or patient pressure
viability we took the example of
vascular leak syndrome so this syndrome
is a side effect of immunotherapy with
oil 2
and it normally affects 1 4 of the
patients that are treated with it
so vls vascular leak syndrome is
normally characterized by
pulmonary edema and therefore a
decreased barrier function and also
cytotoxicity in the epithelium
so what we did is we took other
epithelial cells from different patients
we could culture them with endothelial
cells on our chip
and then we treated them with il2 to see
what happened
it was very interesting to see that only
a subset of these
donors were responding to the treatment
that actually
only certain cells were having this
decrease in the barrier function
and also increase in cytotoxicity as you
can see here in the graphs
however the what we call non-responder
or non-sensitive cells
preserve both the tear function and
cytotoxicity
levels close to the controls
nevertheless what we could detect was
that
the secretion of cytokines happened in
all the patients
so we could say that for sure both were
responding to il2 but only those more
sensitive would be
more susceptible to have a vascular leak
syndrome
so these results show that our system
can replicate this patient-to-patient
variability
showing that it could also be applied in
personalized medicine
as another example we characterized
ourselves for the expression of
a particular type of hla which is
basically the histocompatibility complex
or
mhc in humans and this molecule is
responsible for the self-unknown
self-recognition via the immune system
in this case we were looking for hla a2
and we
just took our primary cells and then
screened them by flow cytometry for it
and we can see
to the left some negative cells and to
the right some positive ones
and these ones we would select and then
grow on the chip
why do we do this so our interest in the
achilles because
there is some antibody based
immunotherapy that requires
particularly hla types to work and hela
are specific to humans so this actually
makes in vitro systems the perfect
approach
since this study we wanted to study the
effect of a t
cell be a specific antibody which brings
together t
cells and epithelial cells
here you can see how it works in this
particular case
this tcb was supposed to be used for
treating a certain type of cancer and
actually it had to be withdrawn in the
late preclinical development
due to a very high toxicity in primates
so what did we do so we took the tcb
and then we treated ourselves with it
and what we could see is that we could
actually replicate this toxicity issue
that was found out
later showing a very strong bird
disruption here you can see the decrease
in tear is very dramatic
and also increase the creation of
pro-inflammatory cytokines
actually if we took them together this
results show
that the language technology can be of
very big advantage in safety studies
so to summarize i hope i have given you
a flavor of how mps
are bringing an increase in value to
inventor research and this can lead
actually to more predictive
new approach methods that have basically
two main benefits first
they represent a 3d alternative in so
that they can help reduce
replace animal tests and besides they
gather human relevant data
for more efficient and cost-effective
molecule development
besides using nps we can target
questions are specific to certain
species and are targeted for instance
for humans
and this has happened for instance with
cov19
in which the receptor for the virus
could not be found and some of the
conventional
animal models are used for research
another example is the targeted
immunotherapy i just showed before
in addition mps are also allowing for
personalized or precision medicine
given that they can capture
patient-to-patient variability
and they are also suited to study
minorities that are
normally excluded from the drug
development pipeline such as those
people suffering from rare diseases of
certain populations
from a technical point of view nps allow
for
conventional and advanced inventory
readouts that have been also developed
for other in vitro systems
and this is an advantage that we can
basically use the
knowledge that we have from before and
just integrate it
into this novel in vitro systems
but of course nps still have a long
journey in front
because they are quite complex and
they're all still not as standardized
so one of the factors that needs to be
taken into consideration is that
we need to work on characterizing deeply
how the cells are behaving in this mps
in this environment so how similar they
are
to the human body another important
factor is their multiplexing capacity
and how we can implement the different
readouts so this can be used in
larger screenings of instance for drugs
or for toxicants
and finally currently there is a lot of
work putting into establishing
different strategies to standardize and
validates the models
so hopefully nps can be included as a
standard procedure for industry and
healthcare applications
not so long in time thanks so much for
listening i hope you have enjoyed the
webinar
and please just get in touch if you have
any questions
you